THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
>> IT WON’T BE A DECADE, I THINK
I’M TOTALLY ECONOMY CAN FULLY
ADJUST AND WE GET THOSE JOBS
BACK.
>> IS NOT HARD TO GET A 20%
UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
SO MUCH ON PPE, HELPING TO LEAD
WHAT THEY SAY WILL LIKELY BE A
V-SHAPED RECOVERY, AND THAT
DOESN’T SEEM VERY CERTAIN AT
ALL.
>> Laura: IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT
MANY ON THE LEFT WERE JUST GIDDY
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO THAT THE
VIRUS HAD DEVASTATED THE BOOMING
TRUMP ECONOMY.
THEY WERE THRILLED.
AND THEY WERE WISH CASTING
GRUESOME JOBS NUMBERS FROM
APRIL, BASICALLY, ALL THE WAY
UNTIL ELECTION DAY, AND THEY
PREDICTED THE ECONOMY WOULD SHED
ANOTHER 8 MILLION JOBS IN MAY.
THEIR HATE AND ANGER TOWARD THIS
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUED TO
CONSUME WHATEVER GOOD JUDGMENT
OR SENSE THEY HAVE.
AND TODAY, THE CREDIBILITY OF
ALL THOSE WHO FORECASTED DOOM
AND GLOOM, WELL, IT TOOK A MAJOR
BODY BLOW WHEN THE STUNNING MAY
JOBS NUMBERS CAME IN.
>> NEW JOBS NUMBERS SHOW THE
U.S. ADDED 2.5 MILLION JOBS IN
MAY, ADDED, THAT’S A BIG
SURPRISE.
>> THIS NUMBER IS HIGHER THAN I
WOULD HAVE PREDICTED.
>> SHOCKING FOR ALL THE RIGHT
REASONS TO SEE THIS NUMBER.
>> DEFINITELY UNDERSCORING THE
FACT THIS WILL HAVE BEEN THE
SHORTEST RECESSION IN HISTORY.
>> Laura: REMEMBER THERE WAS
GOING TO BE NO V-SHAPED
RECOVERY?
WELL, THE NUMBER OF JOBS CREATED
IN THE LAST MONTH BY AMERICAN
ENTREPRENEURS AND BUSINESSES
SHATTERED EVERY RECORD.
THE DOW JUMPED 800 POINTS TODAY.
AND THE MEDIA WAS SO READY TO
POUNCE ON WHAT THEY PRESUME WERE
GOING TO BE THE POOR JOBS
NUMBERS THAT THEY WERE CAUGHT
TOTALLY OFF GUARD.
NOW, THIS MORNING, THE AMAZON
"WASHINGTON POST" TWEETED THIS
GEM.
"GRIM MILESTONE TO BE REACHED AS
MAY UNEMPLOYMENT RATES NEAR
20%."
WELL, THEY DELETED THAT
EMBARRASSMENT, AND THEIR SECOND
ATTEMPT READ "U.S. JOBLESS RATE
UNEXPECTEDLY DECLINED TO 13.3%
IN MAY AMID PANDEMIC."
THESE ARE THE MOST DISHONEST
PEOPLE EVER.
JUST OWN UP TO IT, OKAY?
YOU DETEST TRUMP SO MUCH AND
YOU’VE ALLOWED YOUR OWN BIAS TO
GET IN THE WAY OF WHAT SHOULD BE
REPORTING AND THE REAL DATA
ANALYSIS.
STOCK MARKET WAS OVER 27,000
TODAY, KIDS.
ON ELECTION DAY IN 2016, IT WAS
AT 18,000.
SO, AN HONEST TWEET WOULD HAVE
BEEN, MAY BE, I DON’T KNOW, "IN
SOME JOBS REPORT, INVESTORS
PREFER TRUMP IN A PANDEMIC OVER
THE DEMOCRATS ON THE VERGE OF
VICTORY."
OH, I SHOULD HAVE SENT THAT ONE.
NOW, JUST OVER A WEEK AGO,
REMEMBER, "POLITICO" REPORTED
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE "DREADING A
FULL-BLOWN RECOVERY AHEAD
OF NOVEMBER" ACCORDING TO THE
ARTICLE, THE
POSSIBILITY OF AMERICANS GETTING
BACK TO WORK HAS CAUSED SOME
DEMOCRATS, ESPECIALLY OBAMA
ALONE -- ALUMNI -- AROUND
WASHINGTON TO PANIC.
OH, THEY ARE PANICKING TODAY.
JOE BIDEN WOULD SURELY HAVE
PREFERRED THAT WE STAYED AND
LOCKED DOWN THROUGH THE
ELECTION, MAYBE ALL OF MICHIGAN
WILL FOR ALL I KNOW.
AND HE OFFERED THIS FEEBLE
RESPONSE TO THE STUNNING
ECONOMIC NEWS.
>> THE PRESIDENT WHO TAKES NO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COSTING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THEIR JOBS DESERVE NO
CREDIT ON A FRACTION OF THEM
RETURN.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, IF JOE
WINS THE PRESIDENCY, WE WON’T BE
SEEING THESE TYPES OF NUMBERS
BECAUSE HE’LL IMMEDIATELY MAKE
IT EASIER TO SHIFT MORE JOBS
OVER TO CHINA, LIKE WE USED TO
DO, AND HE WILL GREEN LIGHT
MORE FOREIGN LABOR TO TAKE THE
JOBS THAT AMERICANS WOULD DO.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE POLLS?
I KNOW ALL OF YOU ARE FREAKING
ABOUT THE POLLS.
WELL, THE EXPERTS SAY THAT BIDEN
IS WAY AHEAD.
IT’S HIS ELECTION TO LOSE.
FOLKS LIKE JAMES CARVILLE ARE
PREDICTING A DEMOCRAT WIPEOUT.
EXPERTS SAY AMERICANS WANT MORE
PROGRESSIVE GOVERNMENT.
WELL, THEY SAID THAT IN 2016,
TOO, REMEMBER?
ALL THE SAME PEOPLE MADE ALL THE
SAME PREDICTIONS.
BUT THEN, AS NOW, MOST OF THE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS ARE JUST
HORRIBLY WRONG.
IN FACT, THEY ARE NOT REALLY
EXPERTS IN ANYTHING, I’VE
CONCLUDED.
THE MEDIA FIGURES WHO FURROW
THEIR BROWS AND HUFF AND PUFF
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AT EVERY
TURN AND EVERY TWEET, ALL OF THE
LEFT-WING ECONOMIST, THE SOCIAL
SCIENTISTS WHO ARE DESPERATE TO
USHER IN THEIR ERA OF A NEW
NORMAL, THEY HAVE BEEN
PREDICTING TRUMP’S IMMINENT
POLITICAL DEMISE SINCE DAY ONE.
THEIR PREDICTIONS ABOUT RUSSIA
AND MUELLER, WRONG.
THERE PREDICTIONS ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT, WRONG.
THEIR PREDICTION ABOUT
TRUMP-CHINA TARIFFS, OH, YEAH,
WRONG.
THERE PREDICTIONS ABOUT THE
USMCA.
WRONG.
THERE PREDICTIONS ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS, WRONG.
SOME OF THEIR PREDICTIONS ABOUT
THE SPRING BREAK COVID
SUPER-SPREADER’S?
WRONG.
AND AS I’VE SAID TIME AND AGAIN,
IF YOU COME WITH YOUR COMMON
SENSE, ARE SO MUCH SMARTER THAN
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE WILL EVER
BE, AGAIN, THEY ARE NOT REALLY
EXPERTS, THEY ARE JUST PEOPLE
WHO GO ON TV TO PLAY THE ROLE OF
EXPERTS.
LET’S BE VERY CLEAR: THEY ARE
NOT JUST GETTING IT WRONG TIME
AND AGAIN.
IF THAT WAS ALL IT WAS, THEY
WOULDN’T HAVE JOBS ANYMORE.
THEY ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
ARE PERPETRATING A FRAUD ON YOU
AND AMERICA, AND IN SOME CASES,
IT EVEN COSTING LIVES.
LIKE THAT BOGUS
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE STUDY THAT
WAS PUBLISHED IN THE PRESTIGIOUS
MEDICAL JOURNAL "THE LANCET."
I MEAN, THAT JUST COLLAPSED,
THEY HAD TO RETRACT THE WHOLE
STUDY.
WE ARE GOING TO EXPOSE THAT
LATER IN THE HOUR WITH TWO OF
THE ORIGINAL MEDICINE CABINET
MEMBERS.
DON’T WANT TO MISS THAT.
BUT COUNTRIES ON HOSPITALS,
INCLUDING IN THIS COUNTRY
HOSPITAL, THEY STOPPED ALLOWING
THE USE OF THAT DRUG BASED ON
FALSE DATA.
HOW SCARY IS THAT?
AND THE EXPERTS, BY THE WAY,
LOCKED YOU DOWN FOR WEEKS AND
WEEKS IN YOUR HOMES -- SOME OF
YOU STILL WALK DOWN -- BASED ON
FALSE COVID MORTALITY
PRODUCTIONS.
YOU COULDN’T GO TO YOUR
DAUGHTERS THAT WEDDING, YOUR
SON’S BASEBALL GAME, YOUR KIDS
DIDN’T KNOW MATT COULDN’T GO TO
SCHOOL, YOU MISSED GRADUATIONS
AND ALL OF THESE
LIFE EXPERIENCES, BUT THE MOMENT
THERE WAS AN EVENT OR A PROTEST
THAT THEY THOUGHT WAS IMPORTANT,
ALL THEIR RULES WERE OUT THE
WINDOW.
LOOK AT MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER, OR
PRITZKER IN ILLINOIS.
THE LEFT IS ALWAYS THE SAME --
ALWAYS THE SAME.
YOU WILL SACRIFICE, BUT THEY,
THEY WON’T.
JUST LIKE WITH OBAMACARE,
CLIMATE CHANGE, AND EVERYTHING
ELSE, THE EXPERTS AND
ACADEMIA -- COME ON, THEY’VE
BEEN URGING US TO DO THINGS
LIKE, WHAT COMEDY FUNDS THE
POLICE?
THEY HAVE BEEN URGING THAT FOR
YEARS.
AND THEY SAY IT’S GOING TO LEAD
TO SAFER COMMUNITIES, MORE
TRUST.
WE KNOW THAT IS A FRAUD.
IT’S GOING TO LEAD TO MORE
SUFFERING AND MORE DESTRUCTION,
BUT NOT FOR THE RICH LIBERALS
WHO VOTE FOR BIDEN, OR THE
HASHTAG AND HOLLYWOOD
CELEBRITIES OR THE FORTUNE 500
CEOs.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
AFFECTED, REALLY, BY A DISBANDED
POLICE FORCE.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS, AND THEIR
EXPENSIVE SECURITY SYSTEMS.
THEY CAN FLEET IN THEIR PRIVATE
JETS TO ANY COUNTRY THEY WANT TO
COME ANY TIME OF DAY OR NIGHT.